we are taking calls at 6 1 7 830 for 750
we'll take our next caller from the 305
area code caller what's your name and
where you calling from hey David hey
who's this were you calling from amen
just Terrance i'm calling from miami
awesome what's on your mind I just
wanted to yeah I just wanted to ask you
about this libertarian hypocrisy that I
hear about okay all the time and they
always they always bring up how a
freedom of association and they want to
say oh you have the freedom to not like
Nikki if you're a Christian you have to
like serve people who are gay or you
know because it's a religion but like it
the prophecy comes in when they talk
about like universities not choosing to
talk about like conservative ideologies
nope yeah I mean I think so in not not
to defend discrimination at businesses
on the basis of sexual orientation you
could make the argument that a private
businesses business is different than a
university that receives federal or
state money and that if you receive
federal money at a university then that
there is some responsibility to have you
know diversity of political opinion or
whatever so I think if you were to
present that to a libertarian or right
winger they might come back at you with
that but I'm completely on board with
you about the fact that numerous double
standards exist with regard to wanting
to deny people service at a business on
the basis of sexual orientation but my
prediction is if he presented that
argument to a more astute libertarian or
right winger they would be able to argue
against you pretty strongly either yes
well thanks for talking alright no
problem thank you for taking my call
always great to hear from people in
Miami my I love Miami personally that's
what I don't know about you